all right
all right
all right baby yes baby how far along
are you now
um um well almost nine months
eight months probably eight months in a
week
we probably got like three to three to
four weeks left
and this is you're still living on the
street
yeah i'm still living on an intent
well not even an intent basically on the
street in and out of
different people's tents
and what's your plan here um you have a
baby soon
well i was hoping to get an apartment
but i guess
my plan for now is to go back
to vegas and
see what i could get out there what's in
vegas
just more familiar with the surroundings
and the people and
more comfortable out there than i am out
here being around them
i guess your friends or anything um i
wouldn't call them friends but
i just been out there for four years so
yeah i'm more more comfortable around
all those
people and i know that area a lot
a lot better than out here right you
suppose
you you stopped using you're telling me
um yeah i
like i said i did take some mushrooms
last night but i didn't take like
like two little you know i'm saying
little pieces of mushrooms so
but crystal meth is no longer no crystal
meth i haven't used that
since actually i used twice after i had
that first interview with
you you know like no i haven't
since then so it was probably about two
months after i had my interview was last
time i used crystal mess
and what's the chances of you using when
you get to vegas um you'll be living on
the street there
at first i will be but i'm pretty
comfortable and pretty confident now
that i won't
you know just turn to using when i get
you know i'm saying to the point where i
feel like i have nothing or
all else fails i feel like i could just
it's the baby's almost here
i feel like i can make it at least if i
needed to use i can make it
until after that being responsible
how are you going to support yourself um
i'm going to try
and out there i can get a copy of my my
old id
my tennessee id and with that i can
at least go and get a voucher to get a
real id for california
i mean for uh nevada
whereas out here i don't have none of
that and what will you do
um hopefully i'll just go to at first my
plan is to go to like attempt
a attempt service and just you know day
by day
see if they got work until i can get in
like a program or something
and get referred to like a i want to
open i really want to go back to college
and open up my own business
but uh oh that'll take more time so
right now it's just basically
temp service is my main goal right now
after i get my id
to see how that goes you know
and so you're going to keep the baby um
yeah
i do plan on keeping the baby
i do i really want to have my baby at
home i want to get like a midwife
or something what about going back to
tennessee give anybody um
i would love to go back to tennessee
eventually
but it's way worse out there like
if i go back to tennessee i'm more
likely to just automatically turn to
drugs because
i really that's where all i'm from
that's where all my family's from
but they basically have nothing to do
with me
except for the fact that they take care
of my daughter which
i don't think you know what i'm saying
it's not it's not city it's all country
out there i wouldn't
there's lots of drugs there too i was
cooking mess in vegas
growing up i mean in in tennessee
i probably that's a whole another
addiction in itself
which of course comes along with using
and then i think i'd be more likely to
just turn
back to drugs going to tennessee
especially being that close to my
daughter and not being able to
have have her too
and there's there's a chance of you
losing the baby too right right if i did
yeah if i did i don't that's the last
thing i want
is to lose my baby after i went through
all this
you know what i'm saying just to have
him even though i have used a few times
nobody's perfect you know
i just i don't want to that's not what i
i want to do
but i can't say i'm not going to use in
time
i'll be going through a lot i'll be
stressed out i can't say that's not
going to be a first resort in the future
if it is it is if it's not it's not i
don't want it to be but
did were you how did you get pregnant in
the first place were you thinking that
this was a good thing to do
um no actually it was a one night stand
i just
this dude walked past me on this trip in
vegas and said
some weird freaky stuff and i just
wanted to know what it was about
so i called him and we had sex one night
and i got pregnant
i don't really even know the man
actually he's in prison
federal prison in vegas and i barely
knew his name until he called me from
prison
you tell him he's got a kid coming uh
yeah he knew before he
he found out like two months before he
went to prison
and then he went to prison and i talked
to him
twice and i haven't talked to him since
then
and this was like i was probably three
or four months pregnant
then so that was the last time i talked
to him
but he does know as far as i knew
then he wanted something to do with it
but
i haven't spoken to him since then or
heard anything since so i don't really
know
all i know is he's supposed to get out
in november
which is soon but um we'll see
what happens i just gotta wait on to hit
me up on facebook
hmm
i don't even know what to say i don't
even know
it's crazy [ __ ] it's been crazy
i just feel for your your baby to come
yeah
i feel i feel too and i i don't honestly
i don't even have anything for the baby
yet like i'm
i'm not ready i'm really not but i'm
ready
to do it i guess day by day you know i'm
saying like it's just
tell me your thoughts on birth control i
mean don't do don't you think birth
control maybe
if you were i was on the depot when i
was a
younger but it did make me gain a lot of
weight
honestly i don't i'm not a big fan of
doctors or hospitals
so i don't know about birth control
you know what i'm saying because you got
to go see the doctor for that [ __ ]
yeah but to be having sex with strangers
no
it wasn't that's not something that
always happens
it was just like okay i hear stuff
every day from you know men walking past
and i just kind of ignore it but the man
said something
let me tell you what he said he said i
want to tongue [ __ ] your booty hole
and it caught my attention so i was like
what'd you say you know what i'm saying
i had to turn around and and walk back
to him and ask him like excuse me sir i
just needed to know what you said to me
and when he repeated it i was like oh
yeah i need to know what you're doing
what you're talking about you know what
i'm saying but hey
yeah that's just not something that i
don't
i don't even like sex is not a thing for
me really
but just so happen there you go that one
time
this is what happened all right baby
well thank you for
coming in and giving us an update i wish
you the very best
miraculous happens in your life and
saves your baby from
from a tough life man it's going to be
tough regardless
but you know i just hope that it's a
life changing and for the better you
know
you need that let me help you
get closer to vegas at least yeah thank
you
for interviewing me it's nice to talk to
you again
you look healthy thank you i feel like
[ __ ]
shamu the the whale or something right
now
people keep telling me like you're so
fat you've gained a lot of weight in the
last
you know months yeah
i'm ready i'm ready i told somebody i'm
ready to have this baby thursday i'm
pushing
all right well good luck all right